yeah hello and welcome to our live show
monday evening live show the first one
for three weeks right sets three weeks
or even four weeks I've been away for
quite a bit of time mmm I'd like the
picture quality to be honest somebody
talks a bit off can I improve it hmm
looking very red in the face I mean I I
really got some nice 10 from from the
vacation but it looks a bit weird i
think i have to fix that maybe for the
next session okay let's get going i
haven't played a single game um yeah
I've got a nice tan but not that much
yeah okay so and I haven't played a
single game of blitz chess since the
last session which was almost four weeks
ago I think it was forceful weeks ago
okay let's get going I'm requesting a
game I know that I didn't play that well
back when I stopped for the vacation so
I think my rating is kind of kind of low
so maybe I'm I'm getting game starting
to 291 that's kind of embarrassing
anyway i'm playing a wing tsun here and
see what to do I don't have have only
any non alcoholic it'd be only now let's
see what we can do after
just to solve it I can got an Italian
gay Mia juco piano always hoping for
white to Castle quickly but didn't
happen here night f1 yeah in those cases
I think d5 is kind of interesting but
it's so it always feels a little bit
boring this kind of game okay I can take
here maybe then Queenie seven Bishop is
six hmm i don't have to take right away
okay let's do it and hope it should be
six so what's this Bishop is six you're
going to play Knight f5 I don't think so
so probably here until Queenie sixth
sense very solid it's always difficult
to get something going here in those
super quiet lines and the Italian do you
understand this is a slight issue for
black if you want to do something in
those positions very difficult okay he
tries to get an idea five Sebastian is
asking some cruising the live from the
YouTube we could do quizzes here an
interesting question yeah maybe you
should visually could ask them guys from
here I'd in a chess club account if we
can do kisses yeah yeah I would I think
it's always fun but do you need some
price as out to do curses so I'm going
back to g8 trying to maybe go g6 kick
that night away
um starting a series on the Schleck's
laughs hmm well I don't think it's going
to happen actually meet is serious where
the schlechter is part of it for the SEC
some years ago in German language though
not sure if it is still on and night to
h5 oh you just tries to double attack me
but what happens after g6 hmm as
mentioned I'm kind of rusty but what
happens after this more we'll see yeah I
kind of saw this but I couldn't really
figure out what the point is if I just
go to f6 let's say what's the deal I
don't see where he is going this is the
thing
yeah I could play the berlin wall on the
string why not I mean Berlin is a
perfectly fine opening and I don't
actually think it is that now he loses a
pisa couldn't really do much against us
anymore he wants to go where for here's
the thing and this still can get kind of
tricky for sure I said I have to trade
off this night let's do this so I think
the berlin wall hanging ending X is
actually quite ok are also quite
interesting to play but my objection in
terms of interesting games with the
Berlin is not with the ending but rather
with them other lines especially the
Ruby one line one more five which which
is extremely boring yeah I've played the
the ending and am the bullet in
tournament chess and it wouldn't even
turn out to be so bad it just said I am
I enjoy the classical Ruto PES more it's
just a bit more interesting more complex
I mean complex is wrong but it just has
more pieces on the board I have not
quite sure what mission what my score
was with the Berlin it wasn't too bad I
mean it also wasn't brilliant but I was
kind of okay with it so i don't know i
think i can just do this yeah when g5 I
just go to g7 that's not much going on
here
I is attacking you to which I did not
appreciate fully I mean I can just take
the rook actually or not if you take
some a queen oh my god getting into some
trouble there I don't see it mm okay
I'll take f 52 can I do something else
then it can take it two ears is kind of
annoying that I allowed this
okay I think this should win rather
comfortably so I'm going for it queen of
three seems the only square and then
bishop age for that will promote that we
promote the pawn yes got rookie five but
i can still just promote yeah i play the
tournament portal rush open i forgot
about bishop the bishop move which is
kind of embarrassing can I go nitey for
here I'm making it harm or interest like
that then I should that I should have
don't want to trade actually here don't
want to trade
trying for an attack here Bishop g3
coming rookie to might be on as I want
to finish the game for that I'm going to
tell you a bit about my job open
tournament in port wash how am I going
to win this rook III Bishop d3 maybe or
something along these lines check oh
yeah announcements check hmm Jackie
don't quite see how to win jack quickly
especially quickly as a thing I don't
want to draw either that's the problem
how do I win you a knight and bishop I
need to coordinate better check check
16 seconds oh my god this is not great
is getting this jacketing this this pawn
no I just didn't see that this hangs
okay we can just take this oh my god
what a bad game ah jack okay I think he
could have just taken check okay well
there was a bad game black forfeits on
time well now i should have just won
this of course but okay I need to get
back into strata didn't even play a
warm-up game today it was absolutely
today I just was just sleeping because
the drive back yesterday wasn't about a
complete completely start terrible here
it was like 17 hour drive after that I
was pretty much dead um so um yeah my
tournament in Puerto Rosh didn't didn't
go so well I had a really bad day too I
was some playing okay in the first round
and winning pretty quickly against a
roughly 1900 opponent typical first
round game upper half lower half and
second round I played black against the
play with roughly two thousand one
hundred and it was just like he was
playing a very well I mean he controlled
the position airy nicely and actually
experimented a bit in the opening and I
got a position that I didn't like to be
honest
it was just not not much to my taste
even though objectively speaking the
position wasn't that bad um it was kind
of equal ish for a long time but the
problem was I was spending lots of time
trying to find something in a position
as i mentioned that i didn't like and
somehow I am I lost track and then
blundered pretty badly so I lost round
two um and then it was a double round
two rounds per day so later the same day
um there was around three and this is
one of one of those games are not one of
those I don't really remember having a
game like that before it really feels
like some out of get a very good
experience I cannot really explain what
I was doing in this game I was playing
many moves that don't really feel like I
played them um what's really strange I
was a very very very bad game um which I
which I lost very convincingly very good
game also by my opponent he was rated
roughly 2,000 I'm not quite sure it was
a bit difficult to tell with the local
Slovenian rating and the International
the elo ratings I think you know he was
2000 but I could be wrong roughly this
is this level and yeah as I said I lost
this game as well so I was on one out of
three pretty disastrous just those two
games I'm blundering stuff like that
that's bad okay um I have could before
actually so it didn't work what he was
doing anyway so um what's my rating in
yellow we had 2440 44 before that
tournament I lost a couple of points
yeah those two games alone that cost 18
or 19 ello I was really really
tough yeah then okay at 103 and I am the
only way to kind of make that tournament
tournament okay was to win the rest and
this is actually what I managed I
managed to score six out of six and the
remaining games so it actually didn't
feel that terrible at the end because
well I lost him those very bad games in
round two and three but i also want
seven games i won the most games in the
whole tournament from six games the
winner had six wins and three drawers I
had seven wins two losses and so it
didn't as I said it didn't feel so badly
at the end still it was of course pretty
awful those two games were bad I mean
I'm kind of okay with the first loss not
that I'm happier with losing but it was
a combination of I didn't like the
position my opponent played well and it
was ok the second game was just like I
don't know I really don't know what I
was doing there um yeah the winds were
kind of okay I think of course I
overlooked the odd thing but you always
do it's just like nobody plays perfectly
ever so it was um it wasn't so bad so 24
here what's the deal not perfectly
coordinated chair
yeah 24 is a little bit annoying here I
would really like to coordinate my
pieces back to him
maybe this one yeah so i will also i
will do videos on their tournament i'm
going to start pretty quickly but i have
to sort some things out yet after my
vacation some things you need to need to
be done and when this is this is done
i'm going to cover the tournament on my
channel and the games were kind of
interesting ready it is also the losses
why we're not playing well why am I
playing this so beard and such a weird
way hmm somehow I'm not coordinating my
pieces well in those games here
go ahead you cannot trade routes in
I ask a question if a calm or angry
temperament is better for chess an
interesting question I think um the the
best character trait that you can
possibly have to be very objective that
that's really great of you can manage
that not being overly in love with your
position now just try to see is this
really good and so on yeah just try to
be objective and this is I think helpful
I mean be optimistic this is very
helpful with chess and being optimistic
but it should be kind of within reason
not something like every position is
winning blah blah blah this assistance
this is also very bad but yeah be
optimistic about your chances but try to
be objective objective I have absolutely
no chance of becoming a grandmaster I
can absolutely don't get any time and to
train myself and I mean I'm just not
good enough the way I'm playing my
playing level at the moment is not good
enough so i would have to train a lot
and i don't have the time simply hind
morning yeah and decide what did he
allow that okay it's got to check I
can't check yeah I'm playing very badly
this game Sam I really have to see that
I can improve him I really shouldn't
lose all those games
let's see 994 I had right I should have
done that family ok now it's got five
pawns here who this is not good it's
also very easy to play I love blundering
pieces oh my god he's not taking it ok
night's winning anyway from black pieces
of thing even with pretty much
nonsensical play will win wow it was
clear that i'm i'm very rusty at the bed
check ok have to give this up check
which is losing but still check check
check now King g3 I was pretty stupid
move ok I couldn't do anything anyway
it's just a nose oh my god ok why whoa
resides no not everybody has a chance to
become grandma says that's not true it's
a matter of challenge telling as well I
mean if you simply don't have a very
good talent for chest you won't get a
grandmaster title ok so let's see what I
can do here against the dark past
I can't go in g 3 lakh let's see what
the I can do something with the bogo
yeah I was kind of skeptical with this
check with the session oven I'm going to
relaxed after my holiday it was really a
had a good time but yesterday I mean
have you ever driven like 17 hours
sticking in traffic jams and stuff like
that it was the worst experience ever I
really totally dislike that yeah this is
not a good position unfortunately
well not an easy session
you
pretty awful
I came well what a bad position here I
cannot do anything pretty awful yeah
talent is nice to have her chest but and
working working is all good but it's
just like there there are limits some
people simply cannot get to the Grand
Master time it's not possible simply I
was more I was thinking that wind work
is very important for chess but you need
to have a good basic talent for this and
if you don't have it you don't get to
something like the GM GM title oh my god
and this is this is sucks this totally
sucks this position I think after this I
have to apply one or two games without
looking at the chat so much I mean I
don't watch her ended please check
please ask questions but I want to win a
game there this is terrible losing
crappy games like this who defies nice
playing this all right but maybe I could
have I could have even done this better
I don't know it's pretty awful as it is
I came
Nana not playing with yet there I don't
get me wrong the thing is they've I'm in
better shape I can play somewhat
decently and do answer questions and
shedding but they were playing like a
[ __ ] the chat is tough it's tough to do
Wow the bishop is hanging this is all so
ghetto hanging my god
the only slight slight child is some 95
stuff
he's taking ages what is he doing here I
mean every move Windsor so 495 I guess
okay
okay now i can activate this somehow
somehow here and then we'll be two or
something if I was hanging but you can
not clear actually yeah where I can go I
can take here right it's that so bad
Queen takes and droopy to a dream chaser
I can still play rugby too hmm not sure
that I it's got it all figured out what
a genius wow I don't think we actually
saw that beforehand but it works
beautifully and great
and the Queen e6 is lost I cannot really
do much sharing answers
you
Carrie this is complete his loss but I
did other stuff also it's lost wow wow
what a great session here it's all fun
okay so this was in three losses and
okay gain so I'm going to focus now I'd
win a couple of games already have to
this is just too bad okay making no
sense give this place like he knows it
all this is cool my god
what is going on here and then I made a
mistake yeah actually deal with this
great what a great session I know I'm
already in a bad shape here I have to
play Queenie to our confused to move
over them great great yeah why it is
more or less losing he actually the
structure is lost it's almost losing
this position I have to go Queenie to I
just blended in 29 th five okay
whoa okay so some way here to fight
rights it's really difficult
yeah we came but the bishop is not bad
down it's preventing work before I mean
I didn't even want to play it but
yeah it's just a crap position vault now
you can just take this of course that's
easier
hmm yeah not a happy would include them
yeah the problem is I have a hard time
to get any kind of play it's really
almost impossible to get anything I try
to get the king over to the three
mmm so what to do
stream for a rapid game yeah that's
doable I mean not not here for the asses
see you it may be on a private stream an
issue is sometimes you have those games
they they take take a long time and yeah
let's say you started and it's a very
one-sided game because those pools are
generally not that strong and then now
you're kind of sitting there with an
uninteresting game it's kind of kind of
tricky rep rapid rapid streams yeah ok
so what to do here at least with the
rook on c4 I cannot play before
ok tries to get the King closer kin so
much to do
kind of keep stuff protected 92 94 is
that doing anything that doesn't really
help but okay
yeah I just suffering here with one pawn
down check should just be played at the
Olympics I'm not sure I mean it's
debatable chest chest is definitely
something sports like but I think it's
very difficult to get to get that
accepted of being an Olympic sport I
have to be careful you're not to get my
rope trap check so do i go see for here
I said I don't know let's go see for you
not sure is doing such a great job here
maybe him
okay so i can check here you also try c5
all rights doesn't do that much now g5
is also possible with the text i have
seven porn hmm so hey this is the check
in with the chick doesn't time or head
follow me that much check okay again
this is mostly a check
can see 5 or something new
check
can you go be three or something yeah I
don't think so yeah I think however look
at this move of course as I overlook any
mafia that's kind of making any sense I
shoot I was just about to win this on
time which is kind of haha god damn
check ladies also winning the Rookie
immediately check oh my god what a
session this wasn't actually that bad
check I was kind of happy with the fight
that I put on chad chad is it doing here
check white forfeits nice video on time
okay oh my god oh ok so this is kind of
bad losing [ __ ] started ok ah let's see
Thomas tell us this is a good customer I
usually win against him every game i
have got whatever were too heavy eight
wins one loss so if I'm not winning this
it's getting very very jacked rukh very
critical ok
chain and this is the last one asking
about changing schools and shares three
points for winning one for a draw this
is a nice topic and a favourite topic of
mine three points for witness the most
idiotic idea ever so if this is going to
be is going to be done lot yeah like in
especially in open tournaments then I'm
stopping competitive chess I already do
it's so idiotic this idea so um get help
it never will get employed especially
I'm or regularly employed in in
specimens this is the thing in enclosed
in round-robin tournaments they can do
whatever in service events it's terrible
I mean you have to see there's a very
nice example actually that I can they
can give you and this is my tournament
that I just played yeah I've played it
totally totally badly at unduly bad
event yeah it was really really terrible
and um actually I would have won the
tournament yeah shared first in with
three point system because I want seven
games and I lost elow rating I played
the terrible it was terrible and this is
just not right yeah it's just absolutely
not right I mean it would have been a
total joke in that tournament if I would
have gone shared shared first year with
the rating performance of 2280 where the
other guy was performing 2600 and so
it's it's a totally totally dirty
guardian so what the heck is going on in
this game
to set work I can do this at least this
I'm not winning this game I'm really
getting getting angry it doesn't even
make much sense at the highest level but
I mean usually it's not a big deal so
why I really click and do whatever it's
it's okay but it's a it still doesn't
make much sense okay so what about this
this is hanging 95 no I just cover this
it doesn't make them fight more no this
is also wrong it's just just a bad idea
the only thing what it does and this is
an argument this is definitely the
argument okay I'm keeping it very simple
am it keeps the tournament's open longer
yeah so it's erratically possible let's
say one player is leading the event in
we're three points you can actually
still still tell the the public you know
if the second place guy if he wins like
three games now in a row this is going
to be still interesting which is
actually not the case because who wins
three games in row but it's this made is
a bit more interesting but I need for
the clothes tournaments it's not a big
deal I think it's a bad idea still it's
definitely a completely I mean
completely moronic idea for school
system events
yeah so this is a technically winning
ending I mean at least I shouldn't be
able to screw it up yes mention of the
radio and video that Jen gustavson did
and one of his been tablet sessions
getting into a different kind of your
acting different kind of person let's
say it was kind of funny but I'm not
yeah what's kind of okay let's say I
think it's kind of funny 45 minutes or
10 minutes but not for the cause of a
whole video
okay so how am I actually winning this a
5 p-6 getting this going yeah I followed
the single cab which was a pretty boring
tournament somehow I don't know really I
don't really know why but check it kind
of never really got gone very
interesting somehow I felt like I mean
first of all Carlton was not playing
which is always kind of something mrs.
there and one thing I mean and also they
didn't have any um yeah I will the leg
over I think enterprising players a
little bit somehow there wasn't they day
they never invite I mean I understand
that this is part of the grand chance to
but they never under invite people like
a no report or so who would do something
crazy now and then never cello would be
rubia on again I mean definitely I
didn't I couldn't do anything during
those during this long break of my
holiday um but turn back now I have to
sort some things and then I'm happy to
do black resign to do more on the
channel first thing that I will do
Stephanie cover my my tournament that I
played um it had a couple of interesting
games really i mean the losses the first
loss was interesting to analyze
second one I mean I will show the game
somehow because it's part of the
tournament but it was this kind of weird
experience where you don't really
understand what was going on and yam
gain starting and the winds they were
kind of interesting okay this is Grand
Master correr right our cash I Cora okay
oh wow the pond siani don't see that too
often it's not I mean it's kind of let's
see what he does get same if he is now
this is this is a really bad opening for
what okay lets him
yeah I didn't watch yesterday was it
yesterday the final round or something I
mean yesterday I was driving all the way
back and didn't really follow it I mean
I don't this is by the way this is
something I don't understand it all this
opening for what I mean why this is
worse has to struggle to just stay in
the game yeah Kasparov us finding
improvements on top a lot smooth yeah I
don't think this is a big surprise
actually there should be five is more
interesting as we're so good for where I
look good for black don't know what my
opponent is doing about okay the way I'm
playing it would probably swindle me
okay just goes all the way back so when
am i doing it's just castle they don't
think too long in so this one I don't
know should be good either way I night
I'm not really surprised that um cuz far
off improves on some guys moves there I
mean in a Miss is not playing
competitively anymore but I think in any
in an ending or a middle game position
you can still in analysis more than
compete with them
yeah this position is ok for what he got
something decent out of this maybe I
could have done something better earlier
possible
yeah yeah buckets far off I mean
compared to he's just a better player I
mean he's retired for a long time but in
his prime he would just win events
against all of those guys quite clearly
i mean yeah he players played lots of
those guys and has a tremendous plus
scores against them and the ones he I
mean either a couple of guys he never
played like aronia no Wesley so
obviously but don't think he has to be
very much afraid down okay expecting
Quincy to hear
that's a good move looks like a good
move at least listen to me try to get
the night over to d5
okay so am I getting somewhere here for
maybe I don't know I for I can maybe
just take actually I didn't really think
about him taking which I should have
done pretty bad oh wow discoveries I
didn't really think about the
discoveries here oh my god I'm really ah
three planes route badly the only thing
I do I'm playing quickly business is
this something at least but not good at
all I can't shoot what's really bad in
this session by this I'm blundering lots
of material which I normally don't do
you really don't blunder so much
yeah the time doesn't look good huh we
lost me to take this kind of surprised
I'm not saying that it is bad it was
necessary at all check white resign
hunger so I won this game at least at
the end whoa whoa whoa whoa okay maybe
one more game game started one more game
against Shin and lebon so um no I don't
play the Bundesliga i'm playing for my
hometown club we are playing third
league next season what am I doing here
actually like all the lines in a serious
match against villa what chances do you
give Gary Oh with some preparation that
would have been interesting match i
think i would i would think cares power
was the favorite in this still i mean if
he would do have a preparation I mean
you know he had a huge score against
villa I mean
thing is i believe they they have a
somewhat similar style of play and if
two similar styles of play compete and
one is just better this is often not a
very good recipe for success okay we
have an English opening in against mr.
chanandler bong soon that son he undoes
all song okay so what did you hear many
prepare before I know I haven't switch
to see forward I'm going to play this
little bit more I think ultimately I
like to play all the non è four moves
and switch around according to opponent
I've played a bit of c-4 in that
tournament and it worked out very okay
oh wow that's a sophisticated moves c600
Kasparov we had a great score against
almost anybody that's definitely true
yeah chronic is the only one I kind of
remember no I didn't didn't band what I
guess it's not possible to ban someone
here in the pool there are some people
that didn't have many games against
Kasparov like Boris guaco already
mentioned here in the chat judit polgár
has the worst possible score against
Kasparov Lord he has a good score set1
at least two games
yeah this is a nice position I've got a
queen a for now getting some pressure
here it's not easy for black e'er to get
counterplay yeah Lawrence you're late
this is the final game in the session
and I'm trying to kind of get back into
some decent territory score wise okay um
I think I'm doing take away 6 should
make it difficult for him too yeah this
is interesting but I got I got 95 now
and Bishop e3 okay I'm starting with
this paga has a great school against
honor yes yes I'm something weird score
things so chrome dick has fantastic
school against poor girl but she always
beat fishing 96-94
ah
Queen the 790 choking it should work
kind of hmm kind of noon and maybe it
just goes Ruby 7 it doesn't really lead
to much swidler has never beaten ionic
classical sure that's funny we named a
play for like 20 years which is it makes
it really crazy almost 20 years
yeah physical fitness the chest is very
helpful definitely is I'm Bishop g4 I
kind of kind of getting on my nerves
yeah what are you doing okay i'm just
taking us know him it's trying to break
through I around person I don't
understand how on earth is still so good
yeah well he's really a great player but
can you do it's definitely one of the
strongest players ever okay I would
really like to understand how i can
exploit this better pieces that i have
this one oh I didn't think about this is
it working I was thinking I'm I'm a lot
of peas up here i am i miss couching
this I've got three minor pieces he's
got two right yeah so I have a piece up
that's good news see I can play Bishop
to see three
you
just take this one I mean one thing is
nice he can absolutely not it activate
his rook with the night on b7 at the
point is six on controlling this point
no sir okay so at the end I got some
wings and so I lost the first form and
then 13 year so I'm kind of kind of
getting back in ok I hope you enjoyed
this live stream first one after quite a
longest break I will definitely be on
next term next monday in roughly two
weeks are also have the similarly of
your memo on there so you can play me
yeah ok guys thanks for getting back to
our weekly show bye bye